- Everybody has a tuning
fork inside of them,
and it goes off when you
hit a good golf shot.
Whether you're blind or
fully sighted, you feel that.
My name is Jeremy Poincenot,
and I'm the World Blind Golf Champion.
I'd just turned 19 years old
and was on top of the world,
and then one day, I was walking on campus,
and I noticed I had to
squint to read a sign.
Two months later, I'm legally blind
with no central vision.
This central blur I have is like
a ghostly, fuzzy static
image in the middle
that I can't really see anything through.
- He was a great golfer before.
And, when he lost his vision,
he thought he'd never play again.
- When my mom told me about blind golf,
I thought she was cracking a joke.
But she wasn't kidding.
I said, we can go to the driving range.
I'll hit some balls, and
if I miss one, I'm done.
And I didn't miss one.
The tuning fork went off,
and I could feel that was good.
I like this.
Golf is an individual sport.
Blind golf is very much a team sport.
- My name is Lionel Poincenot,
I'm originally from France,
I'm Jeremy's caddy, coach, guide,
and his dad.
- All blind golfers have a guide,
someone who helps them
out on every single shot.
The first blind golf
tournament we played in,
there was a lot of
bickering back and forth
between my dad and I.
- He would say, well it was your fault,
and it's your fault.
I mean, it was interesting.
- I was paired with someone
who was totally blind.
After the round, I shook his hand
and I said, “John, it was nice playing with you.”
And he said,
"Jeremy, I had a great day today.
"Thank you."
And when he said that, I was like, “Oh man.”
He shot a 324.
I shot a 97.
He's happy, I'm not.
Who's the real winner here?
I said to my dad, “Let’s
play more like John Cosolo.”
- [Lionel] Let's be
happy and enjoy the game.
So, that's what we do, and it's great.
- To feel confident going
into a round of golf,
you want to look good,
you want to feel good,
and then you hope that
translates to playing good.
- [Lionel] You know, he
needs to get loose garments
because you can't swing
with a very tight shirt.
You gotta make sure that he's comfortable
and that he's got
everything he needs to play.
Every player and guide, they
have a different process.
- [Jeremy] He kinda describes the hole.
- [Lionel] If it's tight, if it's long,
and he sets up to the ball.
- [Jeremy] And then from behind,
he looks at how my feet are lined up,
and he tells me to go a little...
- [Together] More right.
- Then more left.
- [Jeremy] I hit the shot,
then we do that the whole
way around the course.
- Good putt.
The first time we went to
the World Championship,
there was no expectations; it'll be fun,
then Jeremy got into the playoffs.
- And I thought, I gotta soak this up.
So I smiled, and I waved to the crowd.
I hit the shot, and it came off perfectly.
After losing my sight, I felt
like I was living a nightmare.
And that moment was a total dream.
And what's especially cool about it
is to be able to share that
experience with my dad.